Where would you go if you received a free one-month
train ticket anywhere in Europe?
Ludivine and her friends already know.
Bulgaria, Denmark, Finland, Italy or Spain.
The idea was launched by the European Parliament in 2016.
What if we, the European Union, offered every 18-year-old European an Interrail ticket,
allowing them for three weeks to discover daily life across Europe?
This idea is now becoming a reality.
This summer, 15,000 18-year-olds have the chance to receive a pass
to discover up to 30 countries in Europe.
Initially, when the idea arose
to give away free Interrail tickets to young people
in order for them to discover the beauties of the continent,
many thought the idea was crazy and questioned its feasibility.
Now we've taken this first step. But it's only the beginning, and we must take it further.
To participate, the young candidates must be 18 on 1 July
and complete a form.
Applications open in June, the journey starts this summer.